we're gonna use AdWords as an example to
help you build the mindset around
creating online campaigns while focusing
on search engine marketing many of the
things you need to consider when
building AdWords campaigns are similar
to what you do in creating any online
campaign such as the structure the
target audience
tracking measurement in more edward's
works by having companies bid for
keywords when a potential customer
searches a keyword in Google search
there is an auction behind the scenes
that automatically resulted with the
winner ads shown up at the top of the
search results winners will be decided
by a formula that takes into
consideration both the relevance of the
ad and the bid so let's get started by
building our AdWords campaign using
abarkment as an example so I'm Andrea I
have been working at Google for about
four years mostly the whole time been
working with AdWords advertising
customers supporting small medium
businesses as well as some of the
fortune 500 companies and so it's given
me a lot of experience to work with all
different advertisers and to see how
AdWords can really be flexible for
advertisers of all kinds all different
businesses with all different goals so
Google is really great as serving as a
platform for advertisers who want to
drive app downloads and specifically I
think Google search is gonna be the best
first step for anyone who wants you
promote their app and Google search is
gonna provide the opportunity for users
to find your app especially when they're
looking for and you know a product that
your app can can meet their needs so for
example if a user is gonna be searching
for shopping apps they're gonna go to
google.com look for Best shopping app
and that's an opportunity where you can
serve your ad for those types of queries
additionally we've just opened up Google
Play inventory so when users are looking
for apps within the Google Play Store
you can now show your ads within the
results on Google Play
so again if a user is looking for
you know shopping or shopping apps or
and you know whatever it might be they
can search within Google Play and
that'll give you an opportunity to show
your ads there as well depending on your
experience with Adwords and setting up
an app promotion campaign is similar to
any other type of Google search campaign
but you know if if you haven't used
AdWords in the past it's really easy to
onboard a user can sign up online
without any support from Google
specifically and so you can just go
online and create an AdWords account but
beyond that you want to create a
campaign specifically for app promotion
and that is an easy process it just
walks you through different steps for
setting up your your budget as well as
your targeting and then you can enter in
your ad creatives so when you set up
your keyword lists you want to remember
to think about themes for your keyword
sets so ideally you separate a couple
different ad groups with different
themes for your keywords you want to be
as specific as possible and as relevant
as possible to your product so again
back to the shopping app you know and
you want to have terms like that would
be related that to a shopping app or you
know best deals online or you know shop
locally those are the type of terms you
want to be thinking about and what's
really the value of your product and
then how do your keywords match up to
your product so keep those you know as
relevant as possible and then also
separate an ad group for your brand
terms so obviously you want to capture
anyone who's searching for your brand
and/or terms that are most similar to
your brand you want to make sure that
anyone who's looking for you is able to
easily find you so those are the things
you want to be thinking about with
keywords you want to make sure they're
just really relevant to your products
your business and then they're going to
capture users when they're searching and
trying to find a product like yours
AdWords is great for small advertisers
for startups it's really a platform that
that allows small advertisers to compete
in the big leagues as well because it
really does come down to the quality of
your product and you know the value
proposition of your business so as long
as you can really communicate that in
your ads and figure out the keywords
that work best for your business then
those are the options that you really
could see yourself perform and and outdo
any of the competitors so that does take
some testing and figuring out which
keywords are best for your business you
want to stray away from some of the
really expensive terms or really broad
terms so you know if I'm selling shoes I
don't want to bid on terms like shoes or
women's shoes that's gonna be really
broad and that's gonna be really
expensive and those are the types of
terms that you might see some of those
big companies they can afford to be
showing ads for those really broad terms
but you want to think you know what is
your product do best and how can you be
as specific as possible to capture the
users that are looking for something
that you can provide so for example if
you know a user is specifically looking
for a certain type of shoe that yourself
that's gonna that's what you want your
keyword and your ad to convey and so I
think that's what's great about AdWords
is that it is an auction and it it does
create a level playing field where you
can decide you know which terms do you
really care about those are the terms
that you're willing to bid on and
pay-per-click and you know if you can
communicate that within your ad and
drive them to the the best landing page
that you can offer a user then I think
you have a really good chance of those
ads delivering for you so one advantage
to Google AdWords is with Android users
we actually don't need to set up any
additional tracking
so we do have a code list tracking and
that's just because you know Google owns
the Android platform so we're able to
know when users download the app you can
see when a user actually clicked on your
ad and when they actually downloaded the
app all within Adwords now as far as iOS
and tracking that that's where you need
an additional tracking system outside of
Google so that's where you're gonna have
to research for a third-party SDKs and
but yeah there's a lot of great things
that you can do too to get started with
AdWords that you that don't require a
lot of additional technical integration
or implementation a lot of it is pretty
much all there for you within Adwords